Ozark season four part one
is finally on Netflix,
bringing the moody intrigue,
rural retaliations
and unexpected twists
we've come to know and love
from the show.
When my uncle first told me
about
your disagreement
with Helen,
my vote was to kill
the two of you.
While we've had to
say goodbye to
some of the lake's
longest serving residents
in season four part one,
it also moved pieces
into place
for an even more explosive
season finale.
With a short wait
before it lands,
fans are mulling over
what they think might happen
when it returns to wrap up
the series for good.
Here's a hint:
it involves
a fair amount of death.
Here are four fan theories
about Ozark
that will blow your mind.
Be careful if you aren't
up to date:
spoilers incoming.
Of course,
we can't forget one of
the biggest question marks
that hangs over season four:
will the Byrdes survive
the car crash?
The first episode starts
in exhilarating fashion
as the Byrde family drive
out of the Ozarks
discussing how there's
only 48 hours left and then…
Dad!
This scene isn't referenced
again
throughout the entirety
of season four,
leading some fans to
speculate that
it's a flash forward
taking place after what
we see during this season
and, possibly,
the very end of the series.
So, we can move back
to Chicago?
Yeah. Yes, we can.
One theory is that it takes
place at the end of the show
foreshadowing
of Byrde's demise.
After years of surviving
the violent attentions
of the cartel,
Kansas city mob, the Snells
and the Langmores,
the family are taken out by
a simple accident:
a moment of dark irony
that would fit with
this show's bleak themes.
According to another theory,
it could be that
the Byrdes' end game is
to go into
witness protection,
staging an accident
so nobody knows
they've moved out
of the Ozarks.
We know they've worked for
the FBI
throughout season four
and this could be part of
their plan to get out.
That's why the truck is on
the wrong side of the road
and doesn't attempt
to swerve out of the way
because it's all
part of the plan.
But maybe,
as some fans have suggested,
the car crash doesn't
actually happen
and is, instead, symbolic of
the upcoming trouble
the family are about to have
with both Ruth Langmore
and Javi Elizonndro.
Considering we're yet to see
what comes of
their confrontation,
it could be a metaphor for
how Ruth and Javi's fight
will derail
the Byrdes' plans
to leave the Ozarks
for good.
We're moving back to Chicago
to keep up.
However,
it's also been argued that
the reason the truck
doesn't swerve
is because it's looking to
actually kill the Byrdes,
which brings us onto
our next theory.
We want you to know that
we know that.
A lot of fans
have speculated that
one of the Byrdes is going
to be kicking the bucket
in the second half
of season four
and there's no end of
theories as to who
or how many it will be.
One of the most popular
theories is that
Wendy is unlikely to make it
back to Chicago as the price
of her ever-growing
rap sheet of felonies grows
and toll of playing her part
in her brother's murder
continues to haunt her.
I can't do this.
Another suggests that,
if Ruth dies, then
poor old Three is driving
the truck
seen in the premiere
attempting to
get payback for
the family's involvement
in the death of his cousin,
as well as the many other
family members
he's lost over the years.
One Reddit post even goes
as far to suggest that
fratricide could be
on the cards,
theorising that
Charlotte could end up
killing her brother Jonah
to mirror the sacrifice
Wendy made with
her brother Ben
when he became detrimental
to the family business.
Maybe their trip to a crypt
at the end of season four
is teasing
their potential fate.
Maybe if you kill me you can
make one of these, too.
With these theories
floating about,
it's clear that fans think
the Byrdes
will have their wings
clipped.
We like your odds!
In season four,
we're introduced to private
investigator Mel Sattem
who's looking for
information on Helen Pierce,
the cartel handler who met
a particularly gruesome end
in season three,
asking the people of the
Ozarks if they've seen her.
Anything at all
from Helen Pierce?
No, sorry.
However,
while Mel says he was hired
by Pierce's husband
to get a signature
on their divorce,
some fans aren't convinced.
This theory goes that Sattem
is actually working for
Omar Navarro as his eyes
and ears on the ground,
which is why Omar knew
where Marty and Wendy hid
Charlotte and Jonah.
Another person he could
end up working with is
FBI agent Maya Miller.
We see the pair chatting
over the phone
in the season four part one
finale.
And, with Maya arresting
Omar Navarro
against her boss' orders,
she could soon be
in need of some friends.
If Mel isn't working for
Omar Navarro,
could he decide to help her
unravel the cartel's plans?
Big fan.
Now, we know
what you're thinking.
Of course Wendy's troubled
brother, Ben, is dead.
After all, we saw Marty burn
his body at the crematorium.
Well, this is where
the slightly more out there
fan theory comes in,
as some believe
that wasn't Ben's body
as we never saw his face.
On top of that,
we never see Nelson,
the cartel hitman,
actually murder Ben,
so there's a chance that
the cartel might be
holding on to him
for leverage.
Although considering
season four deals with
the fall out from his murder
from missing posters
plastered all over town
to Jonah becoming
more antagonistic
towards his parents for
their role in Ben's death…
I was upset because mum
killed Ben.
…It's safe to say that
we shouldn't expect to see
Ben again.
But you never know.
What did you expect, Wendy?
And those are some of
the biggest fan theories
circulating at the moment.
Of course, the only way
to know for sure is
to head back to Ozark
season four.
Part two airs in April.
While you wait,
we'd love to know
what you think will happen
to the Byrdes
in the comments below.
And don't forget to
hit the subscribe
and notifications button
on Still Watching Netflix
to discover more about
your favourite TV shows
and films.